hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
we're gonna review the trailer today for
crimson peak Jerry tell me a little bit
about this movie Jerry for those who
don't know about crimson peak
why don't you refresh them on the minor
information you have as I've been told
it's like it's Guillermo del Toro's like
I think it's a period piece it's like a
vampire movie romance the word has been
thrown around but I can't remember if
this is the right
you mean like I am BAM pyres it's
vampire this is my sister they're parts
of the house the dancing
[Music]
[Music]
terrific imagine two million years
children rather than his children were
confined to the nursery
[Music]
that's the interest proceed with caution
[Music]
I'm here to take you away
there's no outs to go
[Music]
Torro still has it I was told it was
I've always been told as a vampire movie
and it looks vampire II but it's never
explicitly touched a pun you might just
look like a big idiot right now
right it's so cool to see Guillermo del
Toro immediately going back to something
like this after Pacific Rim oh yeah
because what I didn't want to happen was
he kept doing movies like as big of a
scale a specific room I see him back in
line this is like the kind of [ __ ] that
we [ __ ] loved about you you know I
[ __ ] Pan's Labyrinth the fairytale
horror and stuff you know like it's cool
because his films are always like
fantasy in a way yeah well this is
really cool cuz it's going back to you
know like those old like lavish costumes
and big sadness estates and stuff like
that she's very different no it's kind
of it's got a real like old-school vibe
horror vibe about it like well I'm
thinking of like American Horror Story
whenever they like cut to the past and
like the way everyone behaved and stuff
it's it seems very specific it doesn't
seem like the studio's got big control
over this and tried changing it like
this looks very well executed I mean
according to the trailer it's as
ultimate masterpiece
thanks trailer the burden I don't blame
the man he must be Bros with Charlie
Hunnam it's nice to see I know Charlie
Hunnam I got trained you know I like
when directors hat like sort of a mass
like a troupe you know or form a
relationship with a specific actor Mia
Wasikowska
was it cows cow Casca that's how you say
it it's wachowski yes she's the sex
change of I mean this this movie has
like a ton of weird little links because
like Mia Wasikowska and Tom Hiddleston
just did only lovers left alive another
and this yes you know strange Airy movie
together you know you know Tom
Hiddleston is also perfect for like
anything you know any genre Tom
Hiddleston I think and pull off but he's
perfect for
kind of the dark creepy rolls he placed
them with such charm in some ways it
does remind me of like American Horror
Story the first season because it's not
like a simple setup of this is a haunted
house or you know like it goes beyond
that like they're putting you into a
ghost world at this point
well what American Horror Story does and
I mean this doesn't really read as
American Horror Story
esque at all to me what American Horror
Story does is it basically go it takes
that old thing I'm like this house is
like severely haunted because lots of
people have died here but whereas most
movies basically just go okay we'll
focus on the family and miscellaneous
ghosts American Horror Story goes these
are all the people that died here and
we're gonna give them all a personality
and all backstory and this is how [ __ ]
up this one house something tells me
we'll get a sense of that too like I
think you're more del'toro one even if
we don't get like a lot of backstory on
whatever these ghosts are or specific
different creatures because think of
like Pan's Labyrinth like every single
creature in there even the ones you
didn't really hear about like you could
tell there was some type of origin to
these guys oh yeah everything is
orchestrated fleshed out in such a way
that it's like even if you we don't have
to hear the story we get a sense that
it's there yeah exactly and I feel like
we got the same sense here rather than a
bunch of like just throwing in creepy
images and throwing in scares like I
feel like it'll all be really thought
out there's a certain element I think
that comes with his fairy tale
style that you know it's like those are
story like he's telling us a story and
giving us details and yeah it's flourish
it's like really good fantasy or because
it's not in-your-face about any of it
okay now he's just telling a real story
yeah I mean there are certain elements
that are in your face but yeah like that
the nuts and bolts of the story or not
yeah like when she's asking has anyone
died in this house like specific deaths
and stuff like they're showing images of
characters that we didn't get earlier in
the trailer so I read that as they're
showing us like past stories of this so
that's I mean like we're getting full-on
scenes not like [ __ ] quick cool
looking flashback images or something or
they find like a video like it looks
like they're actually cutting back to
the scene we find
yeah I mean if that's what that scene is
intended for because that's like John
isn't it John hurt or hasn't that John
hurt or William hurt one of the hurts I
don't think so
it looks like William Hurt well you're
wrong yeah this is a cool trailer to me
because like I still can't tell what
this story is about it seems like a very
good depiction of what the mood and
imagery would be like so it's enough to
make me go yes I really want to see that
I don't quite know what the story is
other than you know she's probably
intrigued by this house and its
inhabitants and Charlie I was like dude
just be careful like well I'm gathering
that the house is trying to inhabit them
in some fashion like what do you mean
like cuz that's them like it's like keep
them there like they want that that's a
haunting well yeah that's I mean I like
that I don't think they're gonna like
kill them in any way I feel like they're
trying to do one of those like ghost
stories were like we're gonna swallow
you in yeah anything other than broad
strokes that all kinds of stories have
like the stuff that's very specific
about this trailer to me is the mood and
the tone and the costumes and the
settings and what really strikes me to
is the actors in it because this looks
like it'll actually have like genuinely
interesting characters for a horror film
you know or like fat or like a fantasy
horror advanced one thing you know the
tour was really good at is writing
character as well as providing the good
thrills and stuff well because I mean
gehrman tomorrow doesn't strike me as
the kind of guy who writes a formula and
fills it with things he's more of a guy
you take that fairy tale thing it's like
fairy tales are always about you know
characters dealing with a thing and so
he's got that approach and not the same
you know horror movie approach of like I
want to make a haunted house movie how
do I fill the haunted house mold without
paper you know any of you guys if you're
near the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out
Jerry's playlist reasons to GRE movie
reviews on there so check it out and
we're gonna do one shout out
yonder a teddy bear Colbert hey bro can
I get a shout-out oh my goodness another
black friend that's right I'm not like
seven black friends how cool is that I'm
sure you're making even more black
friends by pointing out all the black
friends well I'm trying to say that if
I'm cool with the black community I'm
cool cuz they're the coolest think about
it you could be in a room full of a
bunch of different races but if a black
guys like that [ __ ] is wack you're gonna
be like you know what you're right that
depends on what this [ __ ] is I don't
know I usually just agree with the black
deandre teddy bear Colbert you're the
next mentor of my teddy bear indeed I'm
looking at a photo of you right now you
are one sexy teddy bear mmm I love to
eat you up
yeah I'll lick you like you like
chocolate not because you're black I
didn't make the chocolate things well I
was just saying I like just keep digging
this hole man I'm not digging a hole I'm
trying to keep digging no I think I'm
climbing out of the hole they gonna be
so adorable he's got a photo with you
jabber oh he's got a photo with his afro
what did you new teddy bears others your
shot